- Hey guys, welcome to the
American Music Awards red carpet,
I'm Christian Zamora.
- And I'm Curly Velasquez.
- And we're gonna have Thanksgiving dinner
with all the stars.
- [Curly] ♫ Ahhhh ♫
- Hope you brought your appetite.
- Get ready for a mouth full.
(soft techno music)
- Well, welcome to our
Thanksgiving dinner.
Do you want some bread?
- We really have nothing to offer.
- [Christian] Wax pie.
- That looks so appetizing.
- Does the Black family
have any traditions
for Thanksgiving?
- We always go look at
lights and stuff like that.
All the premature lights around town.
- Oh nice.
- We're a pretty boring family.
- Oh my goodness, wow!
- You don't want him there, trust me.
- But we already celebrated
our Thanksgiving, though.
Because we're Canadian so it's in October.
- Geez, this is awkward,
let's get this out of the way.
- What do you have here?
- Yeah, so, welcome to
Thanksgiving, Charlie.
- Thanksgiving! I'm going
to have a Friendsgiving.
- There you go.
- But I'll FaceTime my mom and dad
and the rest of the family and uh-
- Friendsgiving is more adult-ish.
That's called adulting.
What's the weirdest thing that they've
ever served at Thanksgiving dinner?
- I'm not a fan of lamb or weird meats,
like rabbit and stuff.
- [Christian] I hear you.
- And my family eats that.
- I love all weird meats.
I think you should eat
everything at least once
and then if it's not for
you, you just move on.
- That's true.
- Just like your men.
- I go to all my friend's
houses and all my family houses
and I'm totally greedy.
- Just for the free food?
- Yeah.
- [Christian] That's so smart.
Why make your own Thanksgiving
if you go just eat everyone else's?
- I mean, and it lasts, you know?
- Fuck, marry, kill.
We have mashed potatoes,
we have cranberry sauce,
and pumpkin pie.
- I would marry mashed potatoes
because they're wholesome.
Fuck pumpkin pie because it's hot.
- Duh, it's pumpkin pie.
- That's a legit answer
if you fuck pumpkin pie.
- And then, I guess, poor cranberry sauce,
but I'm gonna have to kill you.
- Pour it down the drain.
- Any celebrity dead or alive
that you could invite over
to your Thanksgiving
dinner, who would it be?
- JLo.
- [Curly] Yes!
- JLo, oh my gosh!
- You know who I feel like
would be really entertaining?
- [Christian] Who?
- Is Madonna.
- [Curly] Madonna!
- See, good answer!
- My family would probably not like her,
but I would be having so much
fun watching them interact.
- Don't you feel like she would make it
all about her at
Thanksgiving dinner though?
- Oh, exactly, it'd be so much fun.
- You'd be like Madonna,
we are praying right now.
- All right, that was Thanksgiving
on the red carpet with Buzzfeed.
I'm Christian Zamora.
- And I'm Curly Velasquez.
- Thanks for watching.
(soft techno music)